now because computer power keeps
doubling every 18 months it means that
that will affect biology specifically
genomics meaning that within 10 years
time I expect us to have a cd-rom with
every single gene in our body costing
about a thousand dollars today to
sequence every gene in your body
becaused
$50,000 that is the cheapest you can
sequence every single gene in your body
because of Moore's law because things
are being computer power it will be
cheaper and cheaper it means that within
a 10 year period of time it means that
that genomics will cost maybe just about
a thousand dollars and that will be the
basis of all your medicine which means
that we'll be able to scan millions of
genomes with a computer and that can
create a revolution in how we
numerically analyze genes for example
let's say we have a million old people
and a million young people we sequence
the genes of old people we sequence the
genes of young people because all of
them have a cd-rom and we subtract that
allows you to isolate where aging takes
place specifically which genes are
damaged in the aging process think of a
car where it is aging take place in a
car well the engine why because that's
where combustion takes place that's
where we have the gum of a depositing
and soot buildup in the engine because
that's where oxidation takes place well
where does oxidation take place in a
cell the mitochondria the mitochondria
is the engine of the cell so we now know
where ageing takes place and by scanning
the genes we'll be able to look at the
genes of the mitochondria and be able to
repair some of those genes and that
could open up a whole new realm of
biology in other words biology will be
reduced to computer science
you